what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
francis nagano versus sir will gain five
rounds battles for the title before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring the notification bell the
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos just to preface i don't
know why i chose to react to this today
like
i genuinely have no idea because i i
don't know who these people are
um i don't even really know what ufc is
i'm assuming like it's fighting but like
what kind of fighting i don't even know
um and i have no idea why this is
trending and it's half a million views
so i'm gonna watch it
guys
sorry guys it's a habit i always put
things into x
the four inches tall and kind of coming
in a little bit lighter from 263 to 257.
see it'll go 247 pounds 2-inch reach
advantage in the red corner within ghana
all right gentlemen we've been over the
rules
protect yourself at all times follow my
instructions we're gonna clean fight
touch gloves let's do it
are title fights
and then there are heavyweight
title fights boy is crazy man excited
much
why are they jumping those knee sleeves
you could be sure god has noticed those
on his opponent frankie i'm gonna bet
who should i bet on i don't i don't have
any knowledge
but i feel like the guy on the right is
gonna win i don't know why
guy on the left just seems too eager
[Applause]
oh
right away
he was too eager he went for the punch
getting close
oh wow wow it's like
they're getting real close francis just
can't load up if he starts loading up
too much it'll fatigue him
now this is where gone excels this is
where he excels
[Applause]
i would just hit someone in the nuts
could you do that
that's how i would win but the action
continues
spinning kick to the body lands forgot a
lot of work here kick to the body
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and if it if it looks pretty then
cylinder feels good
[Applause]
it's almost like they're hugging for a
second that's
an interesting turn of events
body kicks start to add up for gun
halfway
look how casual he is man
[Applause]
[Music]
just under that elbow of sirogon
he's making francis mitch oh
there it is that's what dewey cooper
asks for he goes when he comes in throw
the uppercut
all right little bit of a pedestrian
start round three coming up
and here's a beautiful front kick
nice jab good exchange here right hand
over the top
oh oh
oh my god
i'm sorry guys i was looking at my phone
for a second i think i missed it before
it was in slow-mo oh my god oh my god ow
[Music]
oh
oh my
kind of looks like they're making out
you notice that
[Applause]
let's see
what kind of positioning skills he has
here whether or not he can hold this
well cyril's starting to dig underhook
on the right side cyril's also lifting
up his knees and getting them into play
but we've seen cyril submit people right
yes yeah they haven't seen how do you
win in this do they have to be like
knocked out or
do they have to be pinned for a certain
amount of time or is that wrestling
francis do much of this
oh he's got him flattened out
france is going to start throwing here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and he's doing it well yeah he's doing
really good
oh but now he's going to get himself
reversed
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
there's that spinning elbow we were
talking about earlier he does that off
the break
190 seconds round i'm not gonna lie to
you both of these guys are hot i don't
even
whoo
you guys are good looking good looking
men three and donna with some big misses
tonight yeah he is well that you kind of
anticipated that right because we've
seen everybody fight gone missed that
big didn't miss there
[Applause]
but now francis is tired his hands are
low
he's kind of loading up on his strikes
oh that made him mad that made him so
mad francis goes for another shot
gets to a double
oh no oh come on
oh
he's on the wrong side though
he's got to get his hips out great job
by francine
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a big round for francis
right here you see francis
catch the leg and look at it just power
slam oh wow you love that you got to
love that high impact oh my
wow what the
i mean this is a finishing hey damn near
that's the one two three he goes wizard
kick here
yeah i know i'm saying wow and stuff but
i could not watch this for hours i
couldn't no no no no step across god
does a good job of staying in front of
him
then he tries to duck him
francis just faces faces faces look at
inganu throws the body shot and then
level change to the double
gets the hands locked
so who won each round how do you see i
don't come on man we've never seen we've
never seen this part of francis in
ghana's game
certainly a nice adjustment by and gone
with round three inside leg kick for
gone
like
but then that last one he just touches
him i mean does that count for anything
good body kick from mangano allows him
to get hands clasped behind the back of
khan
france has got two underhooks here you
got the bear hug stepping in front of
the left leg
it's the right thing to do
if he's gonna try to take him forward
but cyril tries to face him now
we would have never imagined that
cyril was fighting so well in round one
and two and francis changes the way the
fight is being fought by taking him down
multiple times
and even in round one in ghana thought
about the takedown yeah
cyril's looking for that kimura again
doesn't have it
francis is on top now though almost in
mount
almost in mount
one minute to go in round four
already north of three minutes of ground
control time and counting for inganu
see the thing is if francis opens up to
try to land strikes it gives cyril the
opportunity to get back up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good job
oh dear shades of silva versus
down 2-0 at one point
big rounds three and four for the champ
i still do not know so i'm guessing the
the white guy lost last round because he
was like on top i don't know
the cereal definitely seems to be the
faster the two
oh my god
this is too
much i i feel like half of this is them
kind of looking up like look it's like
his head is in between his life let's
see if vengano accepts being on his back
yes he is
that's a that is a kill
because when he caught the oceans he was
far too willing to lay on his back
trying to leverage a hit but gone able
to get him back
on his back sort of here
it looks like you're about to try a
triangle yeah
yes it looks like he was about to try a
triangle
mick mainers over here
but that makes no sense that makes no
sense for cyril
yes she probably thought he could get
that that was kind of cool but that
that's a huge mistake that is a fight iq
issue there for cyril gone
huge mistake why why is it a mistake
he's got to move it he's got it again
though
oh no
oh no
i don't get it i don't get it
[Applause]
it's past the knee line yeah he doesn't
have it's okay here francis is fine here
but if you're a guy you got to try to
use this
you got to try to use this to get back
on top
i don't get it he's adjusting oh
oh so it's a certain amount of time
is it points
is it like ice skating
he has had to grapple more in his fight
than he ever has mount
[Applause]
oh my goodness francis
is about to mount him and get to the
arm triangle position
i mean he's gonna try to
use the handcuffs put his hand behind
his back
he's still maintaining top position i
mean he really hasn't done much damage
but this is a long time for top control
much more than cyril ghana's had
final 10 seconds
and it looks as though and ganu will end
the fight in a relatively dominant
position
incredible
does that mean he won't
a tough start
oh so he did i i guess wrong guys sorry
i although
if i was a betting man i wouldn't bet on
me to know the answer so front kick to
the chest partially deflected by cyril
gone
there's a jab behind it and
francis for the kick to the body
oh
that wow
and here's that wheel
bounced
kick
attempt
shoulder on the way in and glanced off
the head
and here's the big slam
when cyril goes to throw this cake
francis catches that leg and just
slams
all 247 pounds of them to the mat
here's francis
attempting and executing a double leg
amazing
jabbed by cyril gone
there's that spitting back kick to the
body sort of that's kind of glanced off
the gut and here's another takedown by
francis
this is the takedown by cyril i mean and
i mean what an amazing opportunity he
was in a great position ladies and
gentlemen
oh wait okay who do i think won
so then he picks who wins
um
okay i'm gonna stick to my original bet
just because
we go to the judge's scorecards for a
decision
the judges scored the contest 48 47 48
47 and 49 46 for the winner by unanimous
decision
and
[Music]
still
ow
okay
maybe i should have known that i don't
know
ufc
heavyweight champion
[Applause]
i need to get
i need to make some friends in fighting
oh my god these guys are so attractive
um
let me know i know this is a little
different than what i normally do but
let me know if you like this type of
content don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time